venom has vanished and morbin time is
over now it's time for Sony's latest
spider villain to take to the screen but
what have we learned from Craven the
Hunter's first trailer
as hype builds for the animated sequel
Spider-Man across the spider-verse Sony
Pictures is Keen to remind everyone that
it dabbles in live action Marvel movies
too next on the docket is Craven the
hunter a film starring Aaron
Taylor-Johnson that revolves around the
infamous Spidey villain since it
features announcement details have been
scarce regarding its plot but the first
trailer premiered at cinemacon 23 giving
Marvel fans an idea of what to expect
from the film according to Ben Pearson
of Slash film The Trailer opens with
Sergey cravenov attacking a truck full
of hunters even goes as far as biting
off one of their noses and spitting an
Epic camera as we hear a voice over from
Russell Crowe's Nikolai cravenov
Craven's father the trailer also
features a montage of craven-killing
unnamed individuals in all manner of
gruesome ways using a bear trap crossbow
Spear and even a saber-toothed Tiger's
suit to eliminate them from his Hit List
the teaser also sees him confront
another iconic Spider-Man foe the Rhino
but not this one
Craven seems like it has all the makings
of a dark bloody action-packed Adventure
worthy of its art rating this could even
be the project to get Sony's live-action
Marvel offerings back on track although
Craven would certainly have its work cut
out for it since Spider-Man made the
jump to the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
2016. Sony has made it a priority to
flesh out his Rogues Gallery at the
movies sadly their efforts have proven
to be something of a mixed bag the
studio Came Out Swinging in 2018 with
the Tom hardy-led Venom which made a
boatload of cash but didn't receive the
most glowing reviews upon release
nevertheless Money Talks so Venom Let
There Be Carnage followed in 2021 a
movie that made less money but managed
to get more fans and Critics on its side
the year after that Sony debuted its
most infamous Spider-Man adjacent title
to date morbius Jared Leto's vampire
flick took the Internet by storm but not
in a good way the movie became a
full-blown meme with its very existence
provoking endless online ridicule for
months on end failing to properly read
the room Sony even re-released it in
theaters all only to find that the
internet's love for it was purely ironic
clearly Sony has had a rough time at the
movies lately could Craven the hunter be
the one to set this Marvel initiative on
the right path it's hard to say but the
movie does at least have a popular
League character as Craven the hunters
remained one of Spider-Man's most
enduring foes the fact this feature film
debut will be rated R is a good sign too
suggesting that Sony is staying true to
what made the character so iconic in the
first place while Craven was introduced
in the 1960s as a big game hunter his
fan appeal went up a notch after the
1987 storyline Cravens last hunt this
rxc's Craven make it his mission to bury
Spider-Man and he technically succeeds
too the hunter then masquerades around
New York as the Webhead before Spidey
rises from the grave when the two meet
face to face again Craven says he has
proven his point and takes his own life
honest tends to be the case with comic
book characters he comes back sooner
rather than later if there was ever a
Spider-Man enemy to get an R-rated Audi
in it's Craven and the first trailer
seems to suggest that Sony is taking the
source material seriously still we won't
know for sure until the film releases on
October 6 2023